hi there steve kaufman here
you know today i'm going to talk about
sort of
the pace
the amount of time how much you know
with what intensity we study languages
and and things that influence that and
i'm going to start by confessing that i
haven't been doing much
arabic learning the last little while
so first of all the reason for that is
that
first of all i had a new floor laid here
in our
little house so that disrupted my
routine
second of all
my wife discovered this
spanish
serial on netflix
called gran hotel and we've been
watching that for two three hours every
evening
so that takes away from my arabic study
time
and it's just a series of things and
then next week we have people coming to
stay with us uh swedish friends
people that i um you know worked with uh
in the lumber business for over 20 years
at least the husband there and they're a
couple coming to visit with us and
that's certainly going to limit the
amount of time i have for arabic
and so it got me to thinking about this
whole issue that when we study languages
when i study a language especially today
i'm studying it for myself
and
there will be periods when for one
reason or another you can't get at you
can't find the time you can't fit it in
and
you know it's unpleasant to put pressure
uh on yourself
and uh you know if i think back for
example
unfortunately now that i've started
learning more languages and i'm putting
up videos every two
or twice a week
i i feel now a greater sense of
obligation to progress in a language
but
when i started all this stuff with
russian which was the first sort of
language that i decided to go after
i mean i think i can't remember but i
think i went a year or more before i
even spoke the language and and i had no
pressure on no one was watching me i
just learn it when i feel like it i i
listen to what i want to read what i
want and it was tremendously enjoyable
when i went from russia to check
even there i think i went six months
without speaking
and uh
yeah some days i'll understand more of
unless and some days i understand less
but there's absolutely no sense of
pressure
now
i say to myself you know i'm
i've been studying arabic now for a
couple of months i haven't spoken i
don't think i could speak
uh
yeah i better get at it
and i think this kind of pressure is is
not a good thing because it makes it
less enjoyable
so um i guess i'm saying
that the fact that i haven't done any
arabic for a couple of days and that
next week
is also going to be a a slow period in
my arabic learning shouldn't matter
i enjoy it so why should i be in a hurry
now obviously
when i was studying chinese or if
someone is at university then there is
some pressure
because you have exams like and even
when i was studying chinese as a
diplomat we had to write this
british foreign service exam so there
are some
objective or external milestones
external demands placed on you
but typically in those situations if
you're a university student or a high
school student that's what you are a
student
you basically can spend as much time as
you want on learning
um or i was paid by my employer to learn
so it's a full-time job
where it's not a full-time job where
you're learning on your own out of
interest
i think it's important to
go at your own pace
uh language learning is not a race
it's not a performance sport you know
every so often i review my comments at
youtube and there's people that come on
and say steve speaks up in such a
language very poorly
even those languages that i know i speak
well like japanese they'll get on there
and say your japanese no good and stuff
like that so that's fine
i think it's important always to
remember
that we learn languages for ourselves
primarily and if we learn languages for
ourselves we will do better if we do if
we learn languages for someone else
maybe we won't do as well and so given
that we learn languages primarily for
ourselves then we learn at our own pace
and circumstances will prevent us from
spending the time that we would like
with the language
that doesn't matter
uh yeah i have my goals i like to do
three stories a day
but recently i've been able to do that
i like to listen and i still do listen
if i have to get in the car to go and
buy something i listen
but if i go through a period where i'm
spending less time on making less
progress
and learning fewer new words
that shouldn't bother me to some extent
it does but i shouldn't let it bother me
because any kind of external pressure
like that reduces the enjoyment and
ultimately our success in language
learning depends on us enjoying the
process so there you have it a few
thoughts on this whole question of
uh
you know
our learning pace and those periods when
we're uh not able to spend as much time
with the language as we would like
i look forward to your comments and if
you enjoy these videos please subscribe
[Music]
you